RYAN BOYD: Hello, everyone.
I hope you're all here for
the OAuth 2 session.
How's your day been
going thus far?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
RYAN BOYD: Good,
good, awesome.
My name is Ryan Boyd,
and I am a developer
advocate here at Google.
OAuth 2 isn't really
my day job.
It's just a passion of mine.
Normally, by the day, I'm
working on our cloud data
services like Google BigQuery,
but OAuth 2 has been a passion
of mine since I started in
Google at about 2006.
I was working on our proprietary
authorization
protocols, AuthSub and
ClientLogin, and I realized
how painful doing authorization
for our APIs was
for developers.
And frankly, I think most
developers spend about 80% of
their time dealing with
authorization, and then the
other 20% of the time dealing
with the actual APIs that they
were using, and that's
kind of sad.
And it was especially
problematic because, back
then, there were these
proprietary protocols across
many different API providers,
so if you learned how to
interact with Google's APIs
using ClientLogin or AuthSub,
and you went over to Yahoo, you
might have to use BBAuth.
You went to other providers,
you have to use other
protocols, and this
is really painful.
So I'm super happy that we've
standardized on OAuth for
authorization.
We had OAuth 1, and that was
still a little bit of painful
for developers to use.
At least, it was standard across
many providers, and now
we're at OAuth 2.
The draft is nearly complete,
any day now, I think.
And with OAuth 2, things got a
lot easier for developers, and
we'll show you how it works.
OAuth 2 is such a passion of
mine that I actually recently
released a book, a few months
ago, with O'Reilly, talking
about OAuth 2.
It's a very short book, but
gives you a good introduction
in about '90 pages, I believe.
So in order to understand
OAuth, we first need to
understand a variety
of different terms.
I went sailing last weekend,
sailing school, and sailing is
all about terminology.
There's way too many terms
even for me to remember.
Hopefully, OAuth will be a
little bit better than that,
but there are various terms.
So we're going to introduce a
couple terms up front here,
and then throughout the talk,
we'll give you some additional
terms that are little bit less
important, but are nonetheless
things that are essential
to understand OAuth.
So the first term is
authorization.
Sorry, authentication.
See, even I'm mixing
these two up.
All right, pause
here a second.
Authentication.
Authentication is about
verifying the identity of a
user, knowing the user is
who they say they are.
When you go and visit a website,
and it asks you to
login, you type a user name
and password, that website
verifies that you've typed the
right password for that
account, and thus has
authenticated you.
It's validated your identity.
But after it authenticates you,
it needs to figure out
what resources you should have
access to, and that's what
authorization is all about,
making sure that you have
access to your data and only
your data, or the very least
only appropriate data.
So if you went and logged into
your email account, and you
had access to your colleague
Tom's email, this
would be a bad thing.
So that's what authorization is
all about, making sure that
you have access to only
the right information.
Questions for you.
How many of you ever shared a
password with an application,
a third party app, so it can
access your data on something
like Google or Twitter
or Facebook?
Raise your hands.
All right, some of you are just
being shy here, because
I'm pretty sure everyone in this
audience has done that at
some point in time, and this is
obviously very bad for the
security of you.
And it's also very bad for the
security of users as, after
all, you guys are developers.
You have plenty of users.
You should never be asking them
for their passwords for
any of the major account
holders.
So you have an opportunity.
You have an opportunity, as
developers, to eliminate the
need for users to reveal the
passwords to your application.
At the same time, you have an
opportunity to restrict the
level of data available to your
application to only what
your application needs in
order to make a good
experience for your users.
And then you have an opportunity
to allow the users
to revoke access to your app
when your application no
longer needs access
to their data.
This is your opportunity, but
it's important to understand.
I believe that you have an
obligation to your users, an
obligation to help keep
your users safe.
And so you have an opportunity,
but also a
responsibility here.
A few more questions for you.
Sorry, that was what
OAuth 2 for
authorization is all about.
Now, we'll get into a
few more questions.
Do you use the same user
name and password
for multiple sites?
How many of you do that?
Tell you a little story here.
Of course, everyone does this.
I think it was like a week or
two ago when some major
website, which I won't name,
managed to get a lot of their
passwords leaked out
onto the web.
And I didn't know about this,
and I looked over at one of my
colleagues, and he was
looking really sad.
And I'm like, Sean, why are you
looking really sad today?
And he told me that now that
his password was leaked out
there on the web, he has to go
change his password, not only
on this site, but on dozens of
other sites around the web,
and he didn't even know
what those sites were.
So he was basically thinking,
you know what, I had some free
time this evening.
No longer do I have any free
time that evening, or maybe
even the next couple days.
So he was really sad about this,
and you don't want to be
in the position of being sad.
And as developers, you don't
want to make your users sad,
or have a risk of making
your users sad.
Another question.
How many keystrokes do you type
when you sign up for a
new account?
Call out some answers.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN BOYD: All right,
all over the board.
Some of you have much
longer passwords
than others, I guess.
I think I type about
50 characters.
I have a relatively short
name even if I
do use longer passwords.
50+ characters.
My first name, my last name,
my email address, password
once, password confirm.
That's a lot of characters
to type when you
sign up for new account.
What if you could drop that
down into two mouse clicks
instead of 50 plus characters
typed on the keyboard?
So again, you have some
opportunities.
You have an opportunity to
minimize the number of
passwords your users
need to remember.
You an opportunity to discourage
reuse of passwords.
And then you have an opportunity
to optimize the
sign up flows for your
application to get users on
board faster.
If you get users on board faster
in your application,
then you get more and more
users, and hopefully, you
become wealthy with
the next IPO.
And this is what OAuth 2.0
for login is about.
And I use that term because
that's the term we use in our
documentation.
Externally, you'll see this as
OpenID Connect or OAuth 2 for
Authentication.
All sorts of different
terms, but they all
mean the same thing.
So our agenda, we talked
about some terminology.
Next we're going to go into
authorization and go through
how you do authorization in
a variety of different
environments, whether you're
in a pure JavaScript
environment on the browser,
or whether you're doing a
server-side environment with
server-side code, or whether
you're doing a mobile
environment, or even some
newer things with service
accounts.
And then we're going to get
into authentication, and
lastly, end up with a set of
resources that will hopefully
be very valuable to you,
including a link to the slides
so you don't need to be
furiously taking notes.
All right, so OAuth 2
for Authorization.
Google has 35+ APIs which
are enabled for OAuth 2
authorization.
Now, I say 35+.
I've had these slides
for a bit.
I tried to count this morning.
There is probably many more
than this, but at least 35
APIs that Google has that you
can use OAuth 2 to get
authorization for, and this is
everything from Calendar and
Contacts to things like
YouTube and Google+.
All the Google APIs, when they
require authorization,
support OAuth 2.
And not only do we have 35
APIs at Google, there are
hundreds of other APIs around
the web, which use OAuth for
authorization.
Many of them are still an OAuth
1, but I'm sure they'll
be upgrading soon to OAuth 2.
Now, your goal when working with
OAuth is to get access to
a user's data in one
of these APIs.
In order to accomplish that
goal, you need to get a token.
This is what a token
looks like.
Well, not really, but
this is a image to
represent an access token.
OAuth 2 works off the concept of
access tokens, and all the
various OAuth flows that we're
going to show you here today,
your goal is to acquire one
of these access tokens.
And this access token if then
used to access an API on
behalf the user.
So in each of the flows, we're
going to show you how to get
an access token.
And then a little bit later in
the presentation, we're going
to actually show you how to
use that access token to
access the API, but trust me,
once you have this access
token, you're all set.
All right, so to get started,
the first thing that you need
to do to get started with OAuth
is to register your
application.
You can visit the Google APIs
console, and you can register
your application, and this
will give you all the
information that you need to
get started with OAuth, in
particular ClientID and also
some other information.
So you can access that now on
the new developers.google.com
site,
developers.goggle.com/console,
and you can register your app.
So let's get into it.
Let's get to the pure
JavaScript flow.
If you're developing client-side
applications that
require only the browser, how
many of you work mostly in
JavaScript?
OK, handful of you.
For those people that like the
server-side code, we're going
to come up with some other
things here later.
But the most simplistic flow is
this pure JavaScript flow,
and it works something
like this.
I'm going to go through a
diagram here, and then I'm
going to go into the
actual code in one
of our client libraries.
And then I assume, because you
guys are in a session on OAuth
2, that you want to know how it
works underneath the cover,
so I'm going to go into the
raw protocol as well.
So the first thing that we have
here, and it's a little
bit small, but we have this fake
app called Taskman, and
Taskman displays your tasks
from your Google Tasks.
And Taskman says to the user we
need access to your Google
Tasks and gives you a button
to click on and say go to
Google to grant authorization.
Pops open a window that looks
something like this, where
Google says that Taskman is
requesting access to your
Google Tasks, and you're
given the option to
allow it or deny it.
If you allow it, it's going to
redirect you back to the
Taskman application.
And you're going to notice here,
at the top right, we
have an access token, and this
access token is in the hash
fragment of the URL.
What that means is this access
token is sent only through the
web browser and doesn't actually
get sent back to the
web server where the Taskman
application is coming from.
It's only in the web browser.
And then in JavaScript code,
we use that access token to
call the Google Tasks
API servers.
And I believe Google Tasks now
supports cores, but you could
also use JSONP and that
sort of thing.
All right, so let's show
you how it works.
I'm going to give you a quick
demo with the real code, and
in this case, the slide deck
is my Taskman application.
So I'm going to say let's see
it in action, and it's going
to pop open-- this is actually a
pop up window, but since I'm
in presentation view, it looks
like I replaced the window.
But I'll hit Allow Access, and
in there are my Google Tasks.
My Google Tasks have been
printed out right in this
presentation.
The beauty of using HTML5 for
your presentations so you can
embed this stuff
right in there.
So this had access,
using JavaScript,
to my Google Tasks.
This was done using the
JavaScript client library, and
the JavaScript client library
to do this sort of thing is
just a handful of
lines of code.
First off, some configuration.
You can see the client_ID.
The client_ID is a value that
we've acquired from the Google
APIs console.
And then we see the scope.
The scope in OAuth is
basically a string.
In Google's terms, we put this
in a URI, and this URI
basically says that my
application's looking for
access to Google Tasks.
You can specify more than one
scope, and I'll show you how
that works later, but for now,
we're asking for Google tasks.
And then there's a callback
handler there, and that
callback handler has access to
the actual access token.
And we just do a quick
JavaScript alert here, and
thus, we've reached our goal,
and we have an access token.
Here's how it works in
JavaScript under the covers,
like I said.
The client library really does
a lot of this for you, but
you're in a session on OAuth,
you probably want to see
what's happening under
the covers.
So here, you're defining a
client_ID, the base of
Google's URLs for
OAuth provider.
The redirect URI.
The redirect URI's simply
the application's URL.
Then the scope, the tasks API
again, and then we're just
building up, concatenating a
string to really ugly, tacky
way, but concatenating
a string together to
build up this URL.
Then we're opening up a popup
window to this URL.
Here's what that
URL looks like.
And that results in a screen
that looks like this.
The user hits Allow.
The user's redirected back
to the application.
And you can see that hash
fragment there, and in that
hash fragment is an
access token.
This is the token that allows
you to access the API on
behalf of the user.
And then there's also
a token_type=bearer.
Basically what this means,
they're called bearer tokens,
and bearer tokens-- all you need
to do to get access to
the user's data on behalf of
a user is to present one of
these bearer tokens.
And OAuth 2 really adds
this simplification.
Most of OAuth 2 does not
require cryptographic
signatures, but it assumes that
your API calls are being
made over SSL, so it's OK to
pass this bearer token in the
actual HTTP request.
And then we have
expires_in=3600.
It's 3,600 seconds
or 60 minutes.
And we reached our goal.
We have this access token.
So questions that
you might have.
We are going to have a Q&A
period at the end.
You can come up to the
microphones at the end, but
I'm going to predict a couple
questions here that you might
have for this particular flow.
And the first is how do you get
the token back from the
popup window back to
the application?
So there's HTML5 postmessage
is one great way to do it.
If you're looking to support
some older web browsers, you
can use window.opener in
JavaScript to pass it back.
I've used both of them.
Both work, but if you're
supporting just modern web
browsers, the HTML5 postmessage
is probably the
best way to go.
How do you get another
access token?
Well, you saw that
that access token
expired in 3,600 seconds.
So in 3,600 seconds, you're
going to need to get another
access token, and you can do
this by running the exact same
flow over again.
So you do the exact same thing,
and only this time
around, the user's not going to
be prompted for access to
their data because the user's
already granted access to
their data.
And this does do the popup
window and all.
You can actually do it without
the pop up window.
There is a way to do that with
OAuth, at least Google's OAuth
provider, and you can ask me
about that later if you have
any questions on that.
But it makes the
user experience
a little bit easier.
And then what happens if the
user's not logged in?
If the user's not logged into
their Google account at the
time they go through this
OAuth flow, they will be
prompted to log in.
So we kind of assume that, most
times, the user is logged
into their Google account, and
so the user will have to log
in if they're not.
So you use the client-side flow
if you're looking for
simplicity.
You'll see the diagram
here soon.
It's a little bit more
complex to use some
of the other flows.
If you like to do coding in
JavaScript, you only need to
access when the user is
logged into Google.
And there's some more
information about our
JavaScript library at a session
that already happened,
but you should be to catch
it on YouTube.
"Building Web Applications that
use Google APIs and the
JavaScript Client for Google
APIs." A very descriptive
session title.
All right, the vast majority of
you seem to not raise your
hand when I asked you if you
code mostly in JavaScript, so
I'm assuming you're looking
for server-side code.
I'm going to show
the server-side
code in Python here.
This is using our
Python library.
We have, I think, nine client
libraries that all support
OAuth 2, so you can use
it in a variety
of different languages.
I'm just using Python
for this demo here.
And we'll start off
with one of these
diagrams, step by step.
The first step looks the same.
The user experience
here is the same.
The user gets prompted and said,
hey, this application
needs access to Google Tasks.
They go over to Google, and
they get this screen.
It looks very similar.
The only difference here is the
line at the bottom that
says it needs access when you're
not at your keyboard.
So in this case, for the
server-side flow, we're
getting access to user's data
even when the user's not
actively logged into
their account.
The user approves, then it
redirects to the application
with this authorization code.
The authorization code, you
notice, is passed in a query
parameter, not in the hash
fragment, and the
authorization code is sort of
intermediate code that's used
to eventually get
an access token.
Because it's passed in the query
parameter, though, it is
passed to the back end web
server of the Taskman
applications.
So the Taskman application gets
that code, and then calls
over to the OAuth provider and
exchanges that code for an
access token, which is then
uses to call the API.
So slightly more complex than
the previous flow, but it has
this added benefit of giving you
the ability to get offline
access to the users data.
So let's step through
it in Python.
A bunch of configuration
stuff up front.
So you can see here, we
have a client_ID,
and we have a scope.
You saw those before.
We additionally have
this client_secret.
This client_secret also comes
from the API's console.
When you register your
application, we give you a
client_secret, and then you
can use this client_secret
with the web server flow here.
You might wonder why do I have
a client_secret here, and I
didn't have a client_secret
in the previous example in
JavaScript.
The client_secret just adds an
additional level of security.
It basically authenticates
your app when your app is
talking to the OAuth provider.
And security is all about
adding these additional
layers, and we think it's
important to add additional
layers when you're getting
higher levels of access.
So in this case, you're getting
access while the
user's offline, so there's a
little bit more security here.
And then you basically just
generate a URL and redirect
the user over to the URL.
This is exact same as you saw
with the JavaScript flow.
The URL will look something
like this.
The only two parameters that are
different in that URL are
the response type of code
instead of Token and then the
access type of Offline, saying
you really do want offline
access to a user's data.
You could also do the
authorization code flow, or
the server to server flow,
without offline access, but
most people are using it because
they need offline.
Here's our approval
prompt screen in a
real screen shot here.
Perform these operations when
I'm not using the application.
And then the user is redirected
back to the
application, and you can see
that authorization code as a
query parameter.
Then the server exchanges that
authorization code for an
access token.
It's really just one
method call here.
The flow step2_exchange,
passing in the request
parameters, which includes
that authorization code.
And we're getting back a
credentials object, and that
credentials object has the
access token in it.
And we've reached our goal.
We have an access token.
You guys excited we have
an access token?
All right.
We also, additionally, have
one other bit of data.
We have a refresh token.
This refresh token used
to get access later.
If we need access after the 60
minutes, we can use this
refresh token to get access.
And we'll show you how that
works here shortly, but first,
I want to show you the raw
protocol of what's happening
underneath the covers for when
you're using this Python code.
It's basically just and HTTPS
post to Google's OAuth
provider, and passing those five
lines there, we have the
grant type of authorization
code, the code itself, and
then the client_secret.
The client_secret, again,
authenticates your application
to the OAuth provider.
And Google returns a nice little
bob of JSON, looks
something like this, and again
you have that access token and
also the refresh token.
So when you want to take that
access token and use it,
normally you would have validity
for 60 minutes here.
But when that's up, and you need
another access token, you
use that refresh token.
So what code do you have to do
exchange that refresh token
for an access token?
There's not much here.
Really just one line of comment
because the client
library actually does
this for you.
The client library automatically
will exchange
your refresh token to get a new
access token as is needed.
But again, you probably want
to know what the client
library's doing under the
covers, and it's really a
simple HTTPS post again.
And this post is saying, here,
I have this refresh token.
Here's my client_secret grant
type refresh token, and again,
getting back a new
access token.
You can do this either when the
token already has expired
and you know it does not work,
or you could do it as soon as
you get a failure, or you
could do it in advance.
You could say, hey, this expires
in 3,600 seconds.
I'm going to start a timer and
automatically refresh in less
than 3,600 seconds.
Our client libraries, I think
most of them actually do this
refresh in advance for you.
It keeps track of the time.
Some of them may actually wait
until it gets a failure.
The difference in performance
isn't huge, but the client
libraries will handle
this for you.
So again, questions that you
might have at this point?
When do these refresh
tokens expire?
Does anyone want to guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN BOYD: Correct.
The refresh tokens never expire
unless the user revokes
access, and some people might
not call that expiration.
But a user can revoke access,
going to their Google accounts
and managing the list of APIs
they've authorized.
And thus your refresh token will
no longer be valid, and
you'll have to start the user
over in the normal flow.
Where do you store these
refresh tokens?
You typically store these
refresh tokens in your
database alongside your
user account.
So you get one refresh token
for every grant of a
particular scope.
If you do a grant of multiple
scopes, which we'll see here
shortly, you'll still get one
refresh token for those
multiple APIs, and you store
those in your user database.
Now, those refresh tokens in
themselves aren't really that
valuable, so it's OK
to just store it
in your user database.
But when combined with
the client_secret,
they are very valuable.
So you want to keep your
client_secret in a secure key
store or something like that on
your server and make sure
to limit access to that
client_secret because combine
the client_secret with a refresh
token, and you get a
new access token for
any of you users.
So I want to show you one
other thing here.
The code before wasn't that
challenging, but we can even
make it easier.
So this is showing you the
decorator flow, or decorator
handler, in the Python
library.
When running on App Engine,
we can just define a few
variables up top, and then just
add this decorator to our
web methods and basically say,
hey, OAuth is required for
this method, and then
we'll handle the
entire flow for you.
Really, you can basically, if
you ignore indentation here
and such, and formatting,
you could do this in
two lines of code.
You can add OAuth support to
your App Engine app in Python
using this decorator method.
So if you want to be lazy,
go for that mechanism.
There's also a OAuth Aware is
another decorator that allows
you to be a little bit more
handle the experience, but
combine these together, if
makes it really easy to
implement OAuth.
So you're looking to your long
lived access to a user data.
Pretty much, if you want long
lived access to a user data,
you have to use the
server-side flow.
You also use the server-side
flow if you need access when
the user isn't at their keyboard
or you need to call
the API from server-side code.
And reminder, I showed this in
Python, but there's a bunch of
different languages that we have
support for, or you can
write your own code.
So you have these tokens we've
reached our goal with both the
client-side JavaScript flow
and with the server-side
flown, and you have
this access token.
Now, how do you use the access
token to access an API?
It's pretty simple.
There's two different ways.
There's the preferred way, which
is using an HTTP header
that looks something
like this.
You make an HTTP request, you
have an authorization header,
you're saying authorization
bearer, and you're putting
that access token there.
That is definitely the much
preferred way, and it is
preferred because authorization
headers are very
rarely logged in a web server
log, very rarely logged by a
proxy server, very rarely
cached, et cetera, et cetera.
So you want to use the HTTP
header whenever possible.
Now, if you're trying to do
JSONP, or trying to do quick
debugging, you may want a
different way to do this, and
you can use a query parameter
and pass in the access token
as a query parameter
in the URL here.
So fairly simple either
way you do it.
It's really just passing that
bearer token in plain text.
But like I said, that plain text
then gets wrapped in SSL
to make sure that this
is all secure.
And if you want to have access
to multiple APIs at once, you
could just do that by specifying
your scope in a
space delimited list.
So the space delimited
list looks like this.
In this case, we're accessing
two separate APIs, and we've
just specified both scopes
separated by a space, and you
use that any time it asks you
for your scope field.
And then the user will be
presented with both APIs.
You can access a bunch of
different APIs it once.
The user has presented it as an
all or nothing decision, so
they have a choice to allow
access to your application for
all of those or none of those.
They can't be selective.
How many of you are developers
that build mobile
applications?
Wow, a lot.
I would think you'd be in
the Android session.
Is there some bad session going
on right now on the
Android track?
Anyway, so mobile authorization,
it typically is
what I've heard it as the
biggest challenge for
developers when working
with authorization.
It's very difficult to work with
authorization, and mobile
apps typically--
because there's not really a
prescriptive way to do it.
You have some decisions
to make and some
trade offs to make.
OAuth 2 got a lot better in
giving some more choice of how
to do this than OAuth 1, and
the spec actually talks a
little bit about mobile apps,
which is helpful.
But in the end, they're really
three different ways that you
can get access on a mobile
application, or for a native
mobile application by OAuth.
The first, which is what
you see here, is an
embedded web view.
This is a cross platform way
that you can get access to a
user's data from a native mobile
device, and basically,
you embed a web view, which is
the OAuth authorization page,
very similar to the URLs that
we saw earlier in the other
flows, and the user gets to
allow or deny access here.
Now, there's some great benefits
to this, considered
by some, which is the
user experience.
You get to see the OAuth
authorization
page in the full screen.
There's not too much
context switching.
But there's also some drawbacks,
and the drawbacks
are in two areas.
One, in the user experience
again, and the drawback with
the user experience is that the
user often times is logged
in on their main web browser
to their Google account.
But since the embedded web view
uses a different cookie
store, they're not actually
logged in here, so they're
asked to type in their user
name and password again.
But that also leads to a
security concern because we're
not seeing the standard
browser Chrome here.
We're not seeing the normal
indicators that this is an SSL
enabled website and the
certificate's been validated
and things like that,
so there's
some security concerns.
The next way, which is also
cross platform, is to use the
system web browser.
Because the user is often
already logged in, this will
just require them to essentially
do one tap to say
Allow Access, and that's
the benefit.
The drawbacks are, in the UX,
it is the standard browser,
there's some context
switching.
The user doesn't look like
they're still in your
application, and then the
other drawback is it's
difficult to communicate the
access token or authorization
code back from the system
web browser back to the
application depending
on the environment.
There are some security concerns
there that you can
ask me later about.
So then the third way.
The third way is
super exciting.
It works only on Android.
And it was just announced and
doesn't quite work just yet,
but very soon in the coming
weeks, and it is the
GoogleAuthUtil mechanism.
This is part of the Google Play
services that we just
announced, and this allows you
to create a much more superior
user experience for your
authorization screen, which
looks something like this.
This is Google handling
it all for you.
So Google is basically--
you make a very simple API
call in your Android app.
Google displays this screen.
The user hits Allow Access.
Your application gets
an access token.
You don't have to deal with the
communication between a
web browser and your
application.
We handle it all for you, and
it's a little more secure
because you're also registering
your Android
application.
Specifically, registering a
signature of your application
as it exists on the Play store,
and that is creating a
client ID for you.
So when a user sees your
application in their account
manager, and they're looking at
the Google accounts page,
they will see your specific
Android application and the
data that they've granted access
to in your application.
It's a pretty small snippet
of code here.
The first thing you need to do
is figure out what account the
user would like to grant
access from.
This is in email
address format.
So there's a way to do that
where you can get a list of
the various accounts
for the user.
You can also have us
render the UI.
There's another call you can
make to us render the UI, but
after you determine what account
you want the user to
grant access to, you
then just determine
your scope like before.
And this one line of
code that says
GoogleAuthUtil.authenticate,
passing in the context you
render out the email address
and the scope.
Makes it so much easier.
So if you're doing cross
platform mechanisms, you might
still have to use the other ways
that I showed you here,
but if you're developing your
application on Android, I
would definitely suggest
looking at this.
And we have our goal.
App-based Authorization.
So app-based authorization
is something different.
What we've seen here before is
how you get access to a user's
data and access data belonging
to that user
on behalf of them.
They're granting you that access
as an application.
But what if your application
needs access to its own data?
What if your application needs
access to data that belongs to
the application and is kind of
for all the users of your
application?
So think of something like
Google Cloud Storage, where
you can store arbitrary binary
files and all, like let's say
your application transcodes a
bunch of videos, or something
like that, and you want to store
the output somewhere.
Google Cloud Storage will allow
you to do that, and you
can upload all these files,
but really, it's your
application's data.
It's not data belonging to any
individual end user, and in
that case, there's a separate
OAuth flow which doesn't
involve the user at all.
It looks something like this.
You have your app server.
Your app server makes a signed
request over to Google OAuth
servers, and this signed request
basically says I'm
looking for this particular
scope, and I'm identifying
myself here, based on this
signature, and give me an
access token.
And then your access token is
used to access the API.
So there's no user
involved here.
There's no web browser
It's just another different way
that you can use the OAuth
2 technology.
The sad part is this
reintroduces signed requests.
How many of you liked signatures
in OAuth 1?
There's a few people.
Even the author of the OAuth 2
spec really wants signatures
to be used every day with OAuth
2, but in this case
here, we do actually
add signatures.
And we add signatures back in,
again, because of the security
through layers.
You're getting access to,
potentially, the data that
belongs to a bunch of different
users, or your
entire application's data, so
you want to add another layer
of security.
And this other layer of
security here is the signature.
So when you register your
application, you get a key.
You use this key to make
signed requests over to
Google, but again, when you're
actually accessing the API,
every time you're accessing the
API, all you're doing is
the same thing you're doing with
all the other flows, and
that is passing this
access token.
Here's how it's done
in Python.
You first load in your private
key that comes from that APIs
console, and then there's a very
simple request here that
you're passing in.
Here's your service account,
which again, you get from the
APIs console.
Here's the scope of data that
you're looking for access to,
and then what that's doing in
this authorize method is,
essentially, calling the OAuth
provider with that signed
request and giving you
an access token back.
Now, I'd recommend, if you're
using this at all, please,
please, use our client
libraries.
Also please, please, make sure
your time on your server is
synced to an NTP server because
that tends to be the
biggest issue developers
have when working with
cryptographic signatures.
But anyway, it's pretty easy.
You can then access cloud
storage on behalf of your
application rather than on
behalf of any individual user.
So OAuth w for Login,
or OAuth 2 for
Authentication or OpenID Connect.
This is really the next
version OpenID.
So OpenID had OpenID
version 2.
Still rather complicated
to use.
I've worked with hundreds of
developers to implement OpenID
2 in their applications,
including some folks I'm
seeing in this room here
today, and it can be
challenging at times.
OAuth 2 for Login builds on
top of the standard OAuth
flows to give you identity or
login or authentication just
the same as you would get
access to a user's data.
So this is really important.
Let's show you how it works.
First of all the traditional
sign-in form.
The traditional sign-in form
is where you're typing your
50+ characters, but you want to
eliminate that down to two
mouse clicks.
So we'll see how that
works here.
I basically click the button
that says sign up with Google.
It pops open and says my slide
deck is requesting permission
to view basic information about
my account and view my
email address.
I'm going to say Allow Access,
and then the application has
my name, my email address, my
profile photo, my Google+
profile, and public information
such as my sex,
date of birth, and
things like that.
Very powerful.
Makes it a lot easier for users
to onboard and use your
application.
So you can make it faster
to onboard users.
You can securely get a unique
stable identifier for the
user's account, so this
is really important.
A lot of times, people
use an identifier
that's their email address.
Developers seem to love the
email address as a unique
identifier.
Users change their email
addresses all the time.
This is not really a good plan,
so in this case, you get
a unique stable identifier
that's just a number that
represents that user on Google,
and you can use that
in your database.
You can also personalize your
site to make your application
a little bit more friendly and
inviting to your users.
So here's how it works.
You first of all specify a scope
that is one of these two
values or both.
So the userinfo.profile gives
you this unique ID, name,
profile photo, a bunch
of information.
And then there's a separate
userinfo.email scope, which
gives you access to the
user's email address.
Now, there's the occasional
geek in the audience that
says, well, what if I don't want
the application to have
access to my email address?
And my response is usually,
well, pretty much every
application on the
web will want to
have your email address.
And those applications do it
already for an email address
and password based system,
so this is no different.
And applications need this
information in order to hook
up with the rest of
their system.
So most developers will end up
specifying both of these, and
then they can request access by
generating a URL that looks
very similar to what we saw,
both with the client-side flow
and the server-side flow.
In this case, we are using
the client-side flow.
We just have our client ID,
we have these scopes, the
multiple scopes delineated by a
space, and the redirect URI,
which is our application's
URL.
There's one other way that you
can do this, and this was
announced just recently, in the
last day or so, as part of
the history API.
You can use our branded button
for a sign-in button as part
of Google+, and that basically
just allows you to get the
redirect and to handle the popup
and all automatically
for you, and then get a access
token in JavaScript.
And again, we've reached
our goal.
So there's this other step with
authentication, the step
that you don't have to take with
authorization, and this
step is verifying the token.
So you call this TokenInfo API,
and basically, what your
goal is here is to make sure
that this token was actually
issued to your application.
It's called an audience check,
so your verifying that that
audience ID there matches the
client ID of your application,
and it's really important
that you do that.
It's really important that you
make sure that this token was
actually issued to your
application and not some other
application, and I can't
stress that enough.
But I won't go into details from
a security prospective as
to why it's important,
but do it.
And so when you call this
TokenInfo API, you get that
audience, you verify
that audience
matches your client ID.
And then you can also get this
unique stable identify, the
user ID, from there.
But if you want to get some
additional information, you
can then call the UserInfo API,
which is, again, just a
REST-based API that you pass
in the access token, and it
returns a JSON responds
with a bunch of
information about the user.
So there are a variety of tools
that you'll want to use
as you're exploring and
learning OAuth.
The first is the OAuth
2 Playground.
The OAuth 2 Playground is a
really helpful application
that helps you learn both
the client-side and the
server-side flows, and it goes
through step-by-step,
explaining what's happening
as you access your data.
And you can use this with both
Google APIs, but you can also
use it with third party APIs
as long as they comply with
the latest version of the
OAuth 2 draft spec.
And it's a really helpful tool
built by a couple of my
colleagues.
And then there's also a demo
that does the exact same thing
with OAuth 2 for Login of
Authentication or OpenID
Connect, whatever you
want to call it.
And it goes step-by-step
through, so you should check
that out as well.
All right, everyone, so I've
gone through in showing you
how to do OAuth both for a
client-side flow, as well as a
server-side flow.
I've talked about how to do
it on mobile applications.
I've talked about how to use
OAuth for identity and logging
users into your site.
I just want to remind you all
that you guys have an
obligation to help keep your
users secure and to make for a
great experience for your users,
and I believe that the
OAuth technologies really
help you do that.
In the latest version of OAuth
2, hopefully you've seen here,
with the exception of a little
bit as cryptographic signature
work there, is much
easier than the
previous versions of OAuth.
So I encourage you all
to check it out
a little bit more.
And here are the various
resources, which I will leave
up while I open this up for Q&A.
And feel free to come to
the mics here if you
have any questions.
AUDIENCE: The ID that comes back
in the audience check, is
that the same as the
other unique IDs?
RYAN BOYD: Yes.
The ID that comes back in the
audience check for the user,
you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, that's the same
ID as would come back via
the UserInfo API as well.
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Question on the Android flow.
The util thing that you
mentioned, is that part of
Jelly Bean, or is that
part of another--
RYAN BOYD: Sorry.
Yeah, I missed that part.
Yes, it is part of what's called
Google Play services,
which is distributed along
with the Play store.
It will be available in FroYo on
up, so pretty much most of
the devices that
are out there.
And I've been told in the coming
weeks is when it'll be
available, but you can check
out the URL there for the
documentation and learn how it
works today and then actually
deploy your app in a few weeks
once it's available.
AUDIENCE: And will this
kind of popup a native
authorization screen and
bypass the entire web?
Because it interacts
with the Android
account manager, I imagine.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, sorry if I
didn't make that clear, but it
does popup the native
authorization screen that
looks something like this.
AUDIENCE: Because there
is currently a native
authorization OAuth 2 screen
that you can use, I think,
from Honeycomb and upwards.
But it doesn't look like this.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, so there's the
account manager version of
the native screen.
There's a few issues, and those
issues are that you
specify your OAuth 2 scope
is like OAuth 2,
colon, and then a string.
And that's often how it's
presented to a user, so it's
kind of a bad user experience.
And then the second thing is
that that token is issued and
assigned basically to that
Android device as opposed to
being assigned to your
individual application, so
when a user goes to manage and
revoke access, it gets a
little confusing.
So we often did not recommend
that you use that because of
those limitations.
Now, with the Google Play
services and the
GoogleAuthUtil, we can
confidently say that's the
best way to do it.
AUDIENCE: And this will be
FroYo and upwards, in
a native way, 100%?
RYAN BOYD: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
RYAN BOYD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, question.
RYAN BOYD: Actually, sorry.
OK, go ahead, and we'll
take him next.
AUDIENCE: OK, we have
multiple devices.
The same client ID as is
in the same user data.
Won't they get the same access
token, or will they get the
different access tokens?
Will they be all valid
access tokens
approximately at the same time?
RYAN BOYD: The access tokens are
valid for an hour, and the
access tokens will be different
access tokens if you
issued them in multiple calls.
The refresh tokens are the long
lived the ones, and you
only get a refresh token,
typically, the first time that
you do the authorization,
where a user
hits the Approve button.
On the Android side-- are
you asking on the
Android side or--
AUDIENCE: No, no, basically I
have two devices, same client
ID accesses the same user data.
Right?
RYAN BOYD: But when you
say devices are--
AUDIENCE: Two devices, say
mobile phone and my desktop
application.
Right?
And they're doing it like
approximately the same time,
might be slightly apart.
RYAN BOYD: You should not get
the same access tokens.
They should be different
access--
AUDIENCE: Different, but my
previous access token, would
it still be valid
for my, say--
RYAN BOYD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's possible to
have multiple access tokens?
RYAN BOYD: It is possible to
have multiple outstanding
access tokens that are valid,
but when a user revokes
access, it will revoke access
to the refresh token and all
outstanding access tokens.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I noticed the refresh
token is longer than
normal tokens, so do you save
the scope inside the refresh
token, or in the server-side?
So you must save the
scope somewhere.
RYAN BOYD: Yes.
With that refresh token, we
associate the scope on
[INAUDIBLE]
provider that that refresh
token is valid for.
AUDIENCE: So basically, the
refresh token, you have some
copy, something to value
the server-side
so make it a longer.
So because refresh tokens
can live forever.
RYAN BOYD: Yes, the refresh
token can be valid forever
until the user revokes access.
If the user goes through
multiple authorization flows
for your application with
different scopes, you'll get
multiple refresh tokens.
But if you just asked for access
to a bunch of different
APIs at once, you'll still have
one refresh token for
those bunch of different APIs.
And we store all that
information server-side.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it will
live forever in
the server-side basically?
RYAN BOYD: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I kind of have a
continuation from the question
before last.
So talking only about Android
devices using GoogleAuthUtil,
if you had the same app and
the same Google account on
multiple Android devices and
access was allowed, say, on a
phone or whatever, would they
have to allow access again on
the tablet, or could you just
use the refresh token there?
RYAN BOYD: So this is a good
plug for the session which is
coming up next in the
Android track, which
I should have announced.
There is a session specifically
on this coming up
next on "Accessing Web APIs
from Android Devices."
[INAUDIBLE]
there would know the answer
to that question.
I don't know the answer.
This is just late breaking
technology.
I haven't actually had
a chance to use it.
We just got it working a couple
days ago, I think.
So yeah, definitely ask them at
the next session or hunt me
down later, and I can find
out the answer for you.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I've introduced
[INAUDIBLE]
mentioned in [INAUDIBLE].
They are based in Google,
but let's say, if I'm an
enterprise, and I already have
directory that is on premise,
how do I use this with
the workflow?
RYAN BOYD: So you've an on
premise directory, like say an
LDAP or active directory
environment, and
you're trying to--
What are you trying
to do, though?
Like you're trying to
grant access to
corporate data or what?
AUDIENCE: I want to take
all my line of business
applications and run them
in Google Cloud.
RYAN BOYD: OK, and you're
trying to make sure the
identity is communicated back?
I mean, one way to
do that is, for
instance, with Google Apps.
With Google Apps, you can have a
SAML provider, and that SAML
provider is basically a service
that runs behind your
firewall on your corporate
network that associates users
with your directory, and then
you're the one that's actually
authenticating those users.
So when the user goes over
through an OAuth flow to
Google, it will basically
delegate then to your SAML
provider, so it'll basically
say, hey, Google doesn't know
how to log this user in.
Let's go to the corporate
directory, and the corporate
directory will handle logging
the user in and then doing the
normal OAuth flow.
So you can kind of bridge
between the internet and
traditional on premise
environments doing
something like that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: How does a two-part
authentication play into this?
RYAN BOYD: So two-part
authentication is basically a
way, for those of you who aren't
familiar with it, to
add an additional layer of
security to your account.
So basically, instead of just
your user name and password,
which is something you'd know,
the second part is something
that you have in your
possession.
So in order to login to My
Accounts, I need to actually
use my mobile device.
It gives me a code that I then
enter into my Google account
when I go to login, and then
combined with my password and
that code, I'm able to login.
It does play well with OAuth
in that, if the user is not
logged into their browser, the
user will be asked to login.
And when the user is asked to
log in, if they haven't used
that browser, they'll be asked
to prove their second
authentication factor at the
time that they login before
any sort of OAuth grant
is going to be issued.
There's no way to, say, force
that or something like that,
to add an additional layer
of security right now.
We supported some things like
that with OpenID 2.
It's called paid provider
off-policy extension.
I'm not aware of, currently, a
way to do that with OAuth 2,
but I would imagine that's
something that will come down
the line with more enterprise
use cases.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, actually
the question I
have is kind of related.
In an enterprise environment, if
I have an application that
needs to access a user's data,
is there a way I can do that
without forcing the user to go
through the whole flow and
say, yeah, OK, I'm going to
login now, and I'm going to
authorize the application?
RYAN BOYD: So we have
another mechanism.
The service account stuff that
I showed you to do app-based
authentication, where the
application is authenticating
and then authorizing
access to data--
that flow could also be used
if there was, say, a
pre-authorization of data.
So if an application was
previously authorized to
access, say, all the user's
Google Calendars in an
organization, there's
a way, when you
make that signed request.
So the application makes a
signed request to the OAuth
provider that says I
need this scope.
There's a way to say I need this
scope for this particular
user, and then use that for this
user-based authorization.
And provided that the user has
previously granted access,
which in the Google Apps world,
happens in the Google
Apps control panel or by
installing an app from the
Google Apps Marketplace, then an
access token will be issued
for that particular user,
and the application
can then access it.
It's not something
I've tried out.
It's something we've launched
just recently, and I haven't
heard many users that
have tried it out.
So if you try it out, and you
have any problems, definitely
let us know, but that
should work for you.
AUDIENCE: Brilliant, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is there an OAuth
2.0 for Login hybrid with
authentication and authorization
as well?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So just the same as we added
multiple scopes for
authentication there, we added
the user profile scope as well
as the email scope.
You can add a bunch of
other scopes as well.
You can ask for calendar or
contacts or YouTube, put that
all in together into one
request, and then it works the
same as the OAuth 1 hybrid
that I believe you're
referring to.
AUDIENCE: OK, and one
other question.
Can you match up the claimed
identities from OpenID with
the ID you get back from
OAuth 2.0 for Login?
RYAN BOYD: For Google
Apps accounts, yes.
For Google Apps accounts, the
identity remains constant
between the different
applications, and I believe
the identity is the
same thing.
The user ID that you see with
OAuth 2 is the same thing as
the ID number that's included
in the OpenID 2.
For regular Google consumer
accounts, the OpenID 2
identifiers are what's called
realm obfuscated.
What that means is as you go
across the various different
applications around the web
with OpenID 2, those
applications are getting
different identifiers for you
as a user where those
applications can't correlate
the information together.
With OAuth 2, that's
not the case.
We no longer realm obfuscate
it, primarily because every
application asks for email
address anyway.
The realm obfuscation is kind
of pointless in some ways.
So the IDs will be different.
We do have a feature request,
which I personally filed.
When you call that UserInfo
API or maybe even the
TokenInfo API to provide you
the old realm obfuscated ID
for you to use, then,
to match the two up.
It's not there yet.
I'm hoping--
I was told this quarter, which
ends in a couple days.
I don't think it's going
to make it in
the next couple days.
They're busy at I/O, but
hopefully in the near future,
we have something like that.
AUDIENCE: In the meantime,
can you just
use the Gmail address?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, so you can use
the email address as long
as you made sure, with OpenID
2, to validate the attribute
exchange signature.
There's some issues with some
applications which never
validated that signature.
So as long as you're sure you
validated that signature when
acquiring the email address,
then you also have a
is_verified value when
you get the email
address from OAuth 2.
If that's verified, and you
validate your signature, you
can be fairly comfortable in
matching those two up.
It's still not as secure as the
user ID, but it gets you
there mostly.
AUDIENCE: When you said earlier
that users change
their email address all
the time, you don't
mean that one, then.
Right?
RYAN BOYD: I don't mean what?
AUDIENCE: You don't mean that
particular address?
RYAN BOYD: No.
I mean, they can.
People get married
or whatever.
You can change your address at
Google, Google Apps accounts,
they can change their address.
So there's going to be
some failure rate.
It's much better to map up over
those IDs, but until we
give you that ability, then
that's your only choice.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So will the user ID
be changed when the user
change password?
RYAN BOYD: The user ID
change when the user
changes their password?
No.
The user ID remains constant.
Look like I have one more.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so if you do the
server-side approach for
the OAuth, do you have to ask
them multiple times on
different device for
permissions?
RYAN BOYD: I do not
believe so.
I believe that we associate that
with the client ID, as
long as you registered your
devices and your web
applications all in the same
APIs console project.
I don't believe that it
will prompt you again.
But if you're talking about on,
like, an Android device or
something like that, I would
definitely ask the folks in
the next session to
be sure of that.
All right, well, so there's
a lot of people
still left in the room.
Thank you.
Hopefully you're here for me
still, and not the next
session, but anyone that asked
any questions, I do have a
couple copies of my book.
So the first people to get
up here without injuring
yourselves, I'll give you a
couple copies of my book.
Thank you.